يرقصون على الفحم المشتعل غير مبالين
باحتراق اجسادهم حفاه الاقدام
لاي شيء يقيهم من حراره الجمل يقفزون في
النار لطرد الارواح الشريره عنهم وتمني
موسم حصاد وفي رثمار
تمكنت اخيرا من الرقص على الجمر وحققت حلم
حياته بهذه الكلمات عبر احد افراد قبيله
باذن في فيتنام عن امنيته في الحياه لكن
لماذا يقوم الفيتناميون باداء هذه الرقصات
ولماذا يعتبرونها مصدر فخر لهم في منطقه
توينكو الواقعه شمال فيتنام النيران هنا
صديقه للزكان يستمتعون بذهبها منذ عشرات
السنين وتمثل مصدرا للارتقاء الروحي
والديني لها قدسيه فريده وهي تميمه حظ
بالنسبه له الرقص او المشي على الفحم من
التقاليد التي يؤديها مجتمع بادئ تبدا
الطقوس الروحيه في الليل بتحضير خنزير
كامل مسلوق وتقديمه كقربان للالهه فوق طبق
مكون من امعاء الخنزير ثم تكدس فروع
الاشجار فيما يشبه البرج بارتفاع يبلغ
مترين وتشعل فيها النيران للحصول على
يقوم الزعيم الديني للقبيله الذي بدوره
يقود الحفل بالعزف على اله وتريه تقليديه
لاستحضار الارواح كي تحل السكينه
والطمانينه على المشاركين في الاحتفال
بحسب ما يعتقدون
يعني
[موسيقى]
يتسابقوا افراد القبيله للمشي حفاه على
كره الجمع والتقاط بقايا الجمر بايديهم
طلبا للصحه جيده وابعاد الارواح الشيطانيه
عن حياتهم تملاهم قناعه دينيه خالصه بان
النيران لن تؤذيهم
لطيف
[موسيقى]
يا ماما
مجتمع باذ يضم نحو 9000 شخص تتساوى فيه
الرجال والنساء في الواجبات والحقوق لكن
طقوس القفز في النار تنحصر على الرجال فقط
هذه الطقوس التي تستمر لساعات يعود
تاريخها للعديد من الاجيال لكنها كانت
تقام سره بعد ان حضرتها السلطات الشيوعيه
في سبعينيات القرن الماضي باعتبارها طقوسا
تعتمد على الخرافات
في اواخر الثمانينيات شهدت فيتنام انفتاح
واسعه وتم تخفيف القيود على رقصه النار
واصبحت تقام بشكل علني وادرجت من قبل
الحكومه على قائمه التراث غير المادي
للبلاد